yeah i said this the other day i said
you you know why is it that
people who would make great statesmen
that make great senators congressman
governors president have no desire to
run
and those who shouldn't are so motivated
to run i know because because it's two
different personality types i think that
uh there's the person that's the
you know hall monitor and then there's
the person doing it look it's the hall
monitor guys running think about it for
a second we need economy fantastic we
need think tank people we need but but
when you're an economist you're not
paying a price for being wrong when
you're an entrepreneur you pay a price
for being wrong you adjust at the price
of pain this is what you know i think it
was uh the book uh
the hell is called uh not black swan but
the other book um
uh skin in the game uh well well well
kind of great book great book because
and it's so true
i think you're going to learn more about
how the economy actually works from an
entrepreneur i'm not saying economists
like paul krugman etc don't have their
place
but they can say whatever they want and
they can push uh um sort of an idea
their hands aren't that dirty i'd like
to see some calluses on your hands you
know what i'm saying so so if so if our
politicians let's just say newsome is a
hall pass guy
what's trump
if if newsom is asking for the hall pass
who would trump be
trump is the wrecking ball
trump's just the giant orange guy who
comes in and goes
chess and he just throws it
and he's like
let's rock and roll you know trump is my
my buddy caddied for clinton
trump
obama
and bush
and caddy is he you learn a lot of
caddying like that so this is a lot of
insider five hours where where was this
was this
my buddy cameron booth yeah in florida
yeah
academy for jordan he was on the tour
great guy
and a hell of a golfer and uh he's he's
not he's he's not a political guy but he
said he said the best golfers trump and
the one guy you'd want to have a beer
with at the end of the day is trump like
like you say what you will about him i i
think the problem with trump is that
he's just such a narcissist he just he's
such a trumpist and i mean he just loves
himself so much and he greats on people
he's probably a bit of a con man i'm
sorry but you got to admit the man's
funny the man cracks me up and he's and
he does have some good ideas when it
comes to the economy 100 i mean so so so
i think where we fall off the market is
when we go he's a you know in la you
can't even have this conversation if you
if i even say
trump's yeah i don't like trump but if i
if i even have a small caveat that there
are some things
you get attacked performing in la you
can't say things like that i do i do i i
have i have and do you really feel it
though oh trust me you feel it i i did
something where i was like i felt bad
for because i know i go where my trump
supporters at that was a i opened with
that so the energy was already it went
to [ __ ] yeah i was like come on there's
and then it was almost like like they
were scared like two or three i go i go
don't be scared of these [ __ ] i go
where are you it was such an awkward and
then i got off stage and the met the gm
and somebody was like hey
you shouldn't i don't think you should
you should take that out of your i go
what a joke that i wanted you you could
say the n word and get away with it
faster than you could say well trump but
i'm not joking in california
so if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
[Music]